morgan wallins dangerous has been the
number one album in this country for
three straight weeks but now
he's in danger of losing it all rachel
smith joins us from nashville where
morgan has set off a firestorm rach kev
he just can't stay out of trouble
morgan is apologizing once again but he
has never faced a backlash
this severe yeah i'm gonna need some
whiskey glasses
who is the real morgan wallen i don't
think i've hidden too much from the
from the public what you see and what
you hear is what you get yeah
the 27 year old country star tells e.t
he is embarrassed and sorry after he was
caught on video
using the n-word outside his home the
video was captured on a neighbor's
doorbell camera as wallin returned home
after a night out in his apology wallen
adds
quote there are no excuses to use this
type of language
ever adding i promise to do better but
was it too little
too late the country star's recording
contract was suspended
this morning radio stations streaming
services
and cmt pulled his recordings and some
of country's biggest stars
including marin morris and kelsey
ballerini were outraged
last october morgan was pulled from
performing on snl
after violating covet protocol by
partying in a bar
he was invited back eight weeks later
you're in big trouble man you're gonna
get kicked off saturday night live
what did you make of the skit that you
participated in you know they were kind
of poking fun of your party in ways
i don't mind you know being
self-deprecating and i enjoyed it really
last may wallen was arrested for public
intoxication
and disorderly conduct what'd you learn
from that experience
i got to be careful of who i keep around
me i think
it can get a little a little muddy
because
everybody doesn't have your best
interests at heart
you